Hi everyone! Today's video is made possible by blinkist.
Get your free 7-day premium trial
at blinkist.com/psych2go
Watch the video to the end for books that we recommend
As creatures of habit, what we do becomes
the embodiment's of who we are. It's misleading
to think that every success story blossoms from talent.
Although talent is a necessary component,
it only makes up a small portion of what is required.
So what does the rest of success entail?
Here are 5 habits of highly successful people
1. They are self-disciplined and commit to their
goals.
Successful people don't rely on instant gratification.
They understand the importance of sticking to their goals if they want to
accomplish them.
Discipline is practiced on a daily basis,
so setting healthy boundaries is a habit commonly exercised.
It's not about being rigid or inflexible.
Instead, discipline means learning not to waste your time
and motivating yourself to keep going, even if the journey
isn't fun at times
Successful people adapt to the healthy mindset that downfalls and
fulfilling undesirable tasks are only temporary
They know that in the long run it'll all be worth it
2 They focus on the big picture
and take small steps every day to paint it
It's a common misconception to think that you have to plan big
in order to succeed
In reality big projects are accomplished from taking
small strides every day
Successful people know how to pace themselves
and learn not to be misguided by the frustrations they face
On details that won't matter 10 years from now
If you want to be successful
always take time to reflect and
focus on why you're doing  this will help you hold
on to your sense
of purpose if at any point you begin to feel lost or
unmotivated
3 They are patient and flexible with their plans of action
Successful people understand that it's not always about work
Sometimes it's about making time to unwind and
relax. Strive for that
balance between life and work to ensure you're also having fun
This prevents you from feeling burnt out and you'll be ready to
tackle your challenges for the next day again.
It's a common misconception to think that the more you work
The more you'll be ahead of the game
When you work yourself into a state of exhaustion
You put yourself in an unproductive, miserable mood
that can cause you to create your worst quality of work.
4 They practice resilience and view their
bad days as learning experiences. It's easy to
get bogged down when something isn't going right but resilience is key
if you want to keep going
Famous people might make their success look easy when you see them in
polished suits smiling for the camera
But there's no such thing as overnight success
They had to fail many times before being recognized
for their hard work. Sacrifices were made
and many nights of uncertainty, doubt, and insecurity were
experienced, but one common habit all successful people
practice is resilience. Learn to
reflect on your bad days and find value in them. Growth doesn't
happen during the good moments. Instead it comes
from experiences of finding the calm within the storm.
5 They are not afraid to carve a path of their own
Successful people don't always stick to the status quo
and are great strategists when it comes to achieving their dreams.
They don't necessarily follow someone else's footsteps and
make their own rules if they have to. When you want to succeed it's
important to remember that staring over can be beneficial in the long run
It may seem daunting at first to abandon months or even
years worth of effort, but if your system isn't helping you grow
then it's probably a good idea to invest your time in another plan.
There's a difference between something that will eventually work and something
that's bound to never work
Use your judgement wisely and strategize effectively.
What habits do you have to help you succeed in life?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Nowadays, it's so hard to find time in our
busy lives to take a moment to sit
to learn something new or something we are curious about
Most people enjoy reading, but struggle in finding the time
to do so. But with the help of blinkist
you can change that entirely. Blinkist is an app
that takes the most important and useful information
from thousands of nonfiction books and condenses
it down in 15 minutes, in which you have the choice to read
or listen to at any time
Currently, there are 8 million users using Blinkist
that are actively exposed to a great selection of topics
ranging from self-help, business, health
and even history books. I've used Blinkist
during my commute to work and love it because
everything you need to know about something is available in less than
15 minutes. I've listened to "The Power of Habits"
by Charles Duhigg and "The Seven Habits of  Highly Effective
People" by Steven Covey. I highly recommend
you sign up. The first 100 people to go to
their website are going to get unlimited access for seven
days to try it out and you will also receive 20%
Off, if you choose to get the full membership.
You can cancel it at anytime during the period
I promise you won't regret it. More information
is in the description box below, so sign up now.